to define a he or she does one need an
advanced degree as a justice she will
opine but who's a woman she can't define
i guess it's time for
what's the big deal
what is the big deal things got absurd
over defining a simple word it's
exchange that grabbed the media by their
hair pieces senator marcia blackburn
asking supreme court justice nominee
katanji brown jackson to define the word
woman
can you provide a definition for the
word woman i can't
you can't
not okay this context
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition
now you know this should only be a tough
question at certain bars that me and hem
are frequent after work
he doesn't want to be left alone what
can i do
so what is the message here other than
in your face women's history month
does she really not know what a woman is
no of course she does she's got two kids
the message here is that language now
trumps nature and it can be changed to
fit whatever narrative the left cooks up
and you know our culture's broken when
saying who's a woman can't be spoken
imagine how absurd that would be if you
needed to consult biologists or any
experts for the most basic questions
hey phil i heard it's your birthday
that's pretty cool is that true uh i
don't know actually let me ask my
genealogist
yeah apparently
had a nice time tonight
have you been drinking though oh uh let
me ask my
hematologist i may have had a few yeah
well that was a great lunch do you think
that sandwich had cheese in it though
i'm lactose intolerant oh i don't know
let me ask my
nutritionist that means yes
and he says i owe him 20 dollars
and he wants to know if he can have your
phone number
[Music]
that is we do not condone bestiality
here
no matter how fun it is
uh weirdo would say oh weirdo thank you
always great when you have to say that
exactly cat uh i believe you claim to be
a woman we don't have a biologist here
to uh actually back that up but can you
can we say confidently that you are a
woman and is this a big deal that you
wouldn't define it i
can i can say confidently that i'm a
woman there you go uh yeah
and it's just one of those things where
i guess that you know obviously there's
this cultural thing and i'm someone if
someone wants to identify as a woman
i'll call you a woman i'll call you she
her
at the same time
you may go through different things i'll
never go through as a trans person but
if you're a trans woman you're never
gonna go through having a vagina yeah
like it's you're not gonna go through
the same things as a person with a
vagina a woman like me goes through and
it's it doesn't make sense to act like
that's not the case um what i have a
vagina ugh my penis identifies as a
vagina which is very confusing when i go
to the doctor identifies him a lot
that's why i got four kids
you know jamie uh there's a lot of
grandstanding in these uh these uh
confirmation hearings and it seems like
it's just
it makes it's yucky i find it yucky what
do you think i find it yucky too it's
it's just and i find it just really
confusing and even as i talk right now
i'm worried what i'm going to say right
because it's so scary like and i and
then the swimming controversy is so
interesting and i was like i don't know
anything and um i think people should be
able to be whatever they want but when
it comes to competitions that's where
you start to feel bad for maybe someone
that came in second or third place that
might not have had the advantage that
you have and i was just thinking maybe
we could do a thing where like maybe you
shouldn't be able to compete in woman
sports if when you win you get an
erection
um
just a thought and then i was thinking
i shouldn't have said that but yeah it's
okay i would but then i was thinking
like how serious could she really be
right about swimming i had friends who
would shave and stuff you got an oar in
the water
um
do you know that the swimmer shaved like
their entire body yeah that's true
that's why i try to convince my
girlfriend to be a competitive swimmer
[Laughter]
jamie
tyrus
let's storm this whole episode up
do you think do you think this was a
gotcha question and it's like she was
just like she wanted to avoid the topic
the topic that jamie refused to avoid
you know unfortunately no yeah you know
this
women are under attack
they're
they're everything that makes a woman
special and unique is being taken from
them and it's very similar
to and i the fact that you always say
history repeats itself but sometimes
it's in a different it's in a different
way but it's the same road it was there
was a time in this country when when
african-americans like myself we had to
like fight to prove we were human it was
logic out there that we were one-eighths
less and we were just something
different you know
now we're seeing that it's coming back
around to where a woman can be is
anything but what she is
like only a woman can give birth to a
child right there has never been
on this planet a human being born with
ovaries and and because of this episode
i
a johnson and
and can create life yeah
only a woman can do that you can do it
in the lab but that's a woman and the
fact that
i was really disappointed that she
couldn't just said
yes i'm a woman i know what a woman is
you know what a woman is but that's the
power of the progressive and the woke
because she would have made a lot of
enemies right for just saying so but
what scares me is you're going to be a
supreme court justice
yeah you're gonna back down from that
what else are you gonna back down from
that's a good point rob do you think she
was just terrified of the woke well i
mean she's got cover because she's she's
on the left side of the aisle so she's
gonna there's not gonna be a problem and
then they own the the hearing and
they're gonna let it pass and all this
stuff but i mean if it's that simple
that she can't identify a woman yet
she's supposed to tell you what the
constitution says i would have followed
up with um okay you're not a biologist
define a biologist what's that you know
come on let's keep it real for a little
bit you're at home doing your own thing
you do you i don't have a problem with
that yeah but it's all this crap this is
from the side that just trust the
science this is not science science is
there's a man and a woman and a woman
gives birth boom and i'm not a biologist
yeah i failed biology yeah i'm surprised
i'm surprised nobody got offended that
she said it was biology that determines
if you're a woman or not that was it
that's a really good point that's a
really good thing it does it does yeah
but that like that's not in the modern
world it's all about construct that
anybody could be a woman to your point
which denigrates the fairer sex there i
said it fairer sex come after me
anybody i'm lonely
coming up
more white house employees vent about
the stumbling vice president